[Music]
my name is Kendall mas I'm from Syria I
came here with my son and 14 July 2016
because I joined my husband he's refugee
here I was happy because I so my husband
and we will begin a new life which I
didn't know anything about and also I
was so sad I just imagined my tears of
my mother the last day so it was
difficult now we are in my first
language school I took the French
language here and this is called sack of
a curve the first step of my life here
and Belgium here people helped us
without expecting anything they didn't I
mean they didn't ask from where we came
what's our background about our
tradition they didn't ask about our
religion any things just helped us
because we are human
[Music]
when I read the sentence like this
socialists and Democrats and I said what
is the Democrat I want to enter this
traineeship I want to learn about the
Democrats because in Syria we are
controlled by a dictatorial regime so we
don't have any experience of democracy I
like very much working and important
human rights like in UNICEF and anything
like this
because I found myself in these things
and I found that I have dreamed to help
people every door I knocked open to me
and welcome for that I want to thank
them the same way I will do the same
thing with other people
[Music]